[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: I'm super
excited to be here today
to be with Danielle Teller, who
is an author and a dear friend.
And I'm going to share just
a little bit about her.
She grew up in Canada, where
she was a bookworm and dreamed
of being a writer.
But she chickened out and
went to medical school
instead and attended
Queen's University
as well as getting
her medical training
at McGill, Brown, and Yale.
She's held faculty physicians
at the University of Pittsburgh
and Harvard where
she investigated
the origins of
chronic lung disease
and taught in the medical
intensive care unit.
Then in 2013, she quit her
job to pursue that childhood
dream of writing.
She co-wrote "Sacred Cows: The
Truth of Divorce and Marriage"
with her husband, our
own beloved Astro Teller.
She has also been a regular
writer for "Quartz" with wit
as well as data.
She writes about controversial
yet accurate unseen
truths hiding behind many
of our long-held beliefs.
And some of my
favorite column titles
include "The idiotic
argument Americans
use in almost every
political debate,"
"Let mom down from the
pedestal: in praise
of the messy, imperfect,
authentic mother," which
was a Mother's Day
writing of course,
"Nearly all our medical
research is wrong,"
"How American parenting is
killing the American marriage."
We're super excited to
have Danielle here today.
And we'll be discussing her book
called "All the Ever Afters."
Before we start
discussing with her,
she's going to do a
little reading for us.
Thank you.
DANIELLE TELLER:
Thank you, Michelle.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm super excited to be here.
And I'm super impressed that
people are taking time out
of their busy work
days to be sure.
I'm very touched.
So thank you.
So I'm going to read the
prologue from the book, which
I think really sets up what
the book is about and gives you
a flavor of the
style of writing,
and in a couple
of sentences just
described the arc of the book.
And then we'll have a chat.
Hopefully all of us
will have a chat.
"Prologue-- The Royal Court.
Suppers at the royal court have
become entirely too oppressive.
It isn't just that
they're interminable
or that we must adhere to
the newest fashions, the face
powder, our hair tortured into
great bejeweled ram's horns,
the silks with sleeves
so tight that it's
impossible to raise one spoon to
one's carefully tinctured lips.
No, the worst is the
gossip, the sinister buzz
of wasps ready to slip
their poisonous stingers
into whatever tender
flesh lies exposed.
This evening I
was ordered to sit
next to the Earl of Bryston, a
pompous halfwit who has rarely
been to court.
He presides over some
godforsaken swamp in the north,
and he seems to believe that
his family's long history
of loyalty to the
crown gives him
the right to opine on the
behaviors of the royal family.
My lady, he said, plucking at
cuffs so voluminous that they
draped into his
suit, I understand
that your nubile
daughters are not yet wed.
No, my Lord, I
answered as briefly
as courtesy would allow.
And yet, I've heard
that they once
vied for the attention
of Prince Henry himself.
The earl dabbed his
crimson lips daintily.
That they tried to
alienate his affection
from Princess Elfilda.
You seem amused, my lord.
He could not have mistaken
the coldness in my response.
I fear that much of what
you have heard is not true.
Ah, well, it is an
incredible tale.
He smiled broadly.
The beautiful
downtrodden maiden who
ascends to the royal palace,
the jealous stepsisters,
the glass slipper
that would not fit.
My lord, I cannot
credit such a tale.
Ah, come, my lady, you
know that the whole kingdom
is enthralled by our radiant
and benevolent princess.
I've heard a great deal
about you and your daughters.
He looked at me knowingly.
Compelling fiction often
obscures the humble truth.
I do hope that you'll
tell me about the slipper,
he said, ignoring my reluctance.
He broke a piece of bread
leaving a trail of crumbs
across the table.
My wife is frantic to
know the particulars.
They say that the prince let
every maiden try the shoe even
your daughters.
He laughed.
It is droll to imagine
them receiving attention
from a prince.
Well, his shrug was eloquent.
They are ugly and
Elfilda is beautiful.
The Earl frowned
and pursed his lips.
It's genteel to
imply nasty insults
not to speak them directly.
My lord, I may have heard some
of the rumors to which you
allude.
To my mind, these
stories insinuate
a plague of blindness.
Prince Henry would have to
be blind not to recognize
the object of his admiration
or to distinguish an ugly girl
from one of unsurpassed beauty.
My daughters would need to
be blind to their reflections
in the mirrors and on the
faces of those who behold them.
My voice rose, so I paused
and began again blandly.
They would also need to
be blind to the truth
that men persuade themselves
that beautiful women possess
virtue and good character,
whereas no amount of virtue
can make an ugly
woman beautiful.
Ah, my lady, Princess
Elfilda that a dazzling star
who shines in the royal
firmament where she belongs.
He did not attempt to
conceal his disdain.
That she invites you
and your daughters
to dine here at the palace is
a testament to her compassion,
forgiveness, and generosity.
Indeed, my Lord, I murmured.
Indeed that is so.
I'm only of interest
to the Earl of Bryston
and his ilk because
of my stepdaughter.
Princess Elfilda is the
most celebrated woman
in the kingdom, perhaps
in all of history.
Commoners line the
streets for endless hours
even in dark and sleet
hoping to glimpse
her face through the window
of her gilded carriage.
When the princess has
a gown cut in a new way
or adopts a different
hairstyle, every female creature
in the city imitates
her appearance.
Last autumn she wore a choker of
pearls to church on Michaelmas.
And the next day every
noble woman's throat
was wound snugly with
pearls or other jewels.
By Christmastide,
even the peasant girls
wore chokers of beads
or ribbon, whatever
material they could find
to replicate the fashion.
Princess Elfilda's popularity
derives in large part
from her astonishing beauty.
There's something
else about her nature
that attracts the masses.
Her habitual muteness
and the gentle hesitancy
of those rare words that
do fall from her lips
make her seem bashful as does
her manner of ducking her head
and looking up through
sweeping lashes.
Apart from her collection
of bobbles and kennel
of favorite dogs, she appears
to have no passions or vises.
And when she attends
royal functions,
her gaze drifts to
invisible spectacles
that only she can apprehend.
Her elusive character
is a blank parchment
upon which any story
may be written.
And every girl who dreams
of becoming a princess
can imagine herself
in Princess Elfilda's
to famously tiny shoes.
I know more of the princess's
history than anyone else alive,
and the true tale is not as
fantastical as the one sung
by troubadours.
Nobody's interested in the
story of a flesh-and-blood's
nobleman's daughter, one who wet
her bed, complained of boredom,
fought with her kin, and turned
up her nose at winter greens
just like any mortal child.
Nor do I have any desire
to diminish the adulation
for the princess, which
makes both the admiring
and the admired so content.
I do not set out to write
the princess's history,
but my own, the only tale I
have the authority to tell.
My quill me resurrect
ghosts to keep
me company during the
long days at the castle.
And if it cannot, at least
my mind will be occupied
and my hands busy.
As for fables about good and
evil and songs about glass
slippers, I shall leave
those to the minstrels.
They can invent their own
tales about Cinderella."
So that's the prologue,
which I think sort of sets
up the book in that
she's going to tell
her story from her perspective.
And it really is the
story of her life.
So it starts from when
she is about 10 years old.
And we follow her
till she's about 50.
And I think of it as kind
of a nested fairy tale,
where Agnes has her own
rags-to-rich arc of her life.
And then toward the last
third or quarter of the book
we get much more of the
Cinderella elements,
and we get sort of Cinderella
story embedded in the longer
story of the stepmother's life.
So I'll leave it at that,
and we can have a chat.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN:
Great, yeah, I
have questions that I
wanted to ask Danielle,
but then we want to
open it up to the group
too and have a discussion.
And hopefully you guys all
have questions for her as well.
But I'd love to start with--
this is your first
piece of fiction.
Everything before has been
very factual, and interesting,
and beautiful.
But this is fiction.
What drove you to this
methodology of writing?
DANIELLE TELLER:
Well, I had always
wanted to be in
novelist my entire life.
And I took a very,
very long detour
through medicine, and
science, and nonfiction.
And sort of finally got
back to my true love.
And I think that
fiction is one more
way in which we can examine
our lives and the world
that we live in.
I think it's a tool that can
make us think differently
about our everyday lives.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: So true.
And how did you come up then
with this particular idea
of the retelling of Cinderella
from her stepmother's
perspective?
DANIELLE TELLER: So I
had had a different novel
in the back of my
mind for a long time.
But then I became
a stepmother, and I
spent a lot of time thinking
about being a stepmother
because it was something
that I struggled with.
You don't grow up
thinking, when I grow up,
I want to be a stepmom.
It just happens to you,
and you haven't usually
thought it through.
And I was really surprised
at how challenging
a relationship that was.
And what I realized
with that there
are a lot of
intrinsic difficulties
in the relationship.
Because for the
child, especially
if it's due to
divorce-- so the child
already has two loving parents.
Welcoming another
parent into their lives
is not something that
they are looking to do.
They don't want
this other stranger
coming into their lives,
and ordering them around,
and changing their routines, and
sucking up the attention of one
of their parents.
It's sort of a negative if
they already feel supported,
and loved, and have
everything that they need
from their biological parents.
And also, for the stepparents,
I realize it's also challenging.
Because I think we make
a lot of assumptions
about human relationships.
And one of the
assumptions we make
is that if you are an adult and
you enter into a child's life,
that you are automatically
going to love that child
and that child is automatically
going to love you back.
But it doesn't
always work that way.
It takes time.
When you have your
own child, I think
that mother nature gives us
the gift of this bond when
your child is born.
But being a stepparent is a bit
like your kid bringing a friend
home, and then all
of a sudden you
have to be a parent
to that friend.
So you don't know
that child as well.
You don't necessarily
have that bond already.
And especially if
they have resentments,
they don't see you as a net
positive in their lives.
It can be a really
challenging relationship
because you have to do all
the stuff for the child
that you do for your own child.
You have to cook, and
clean, and care for them,
and drive them around.
But they don't necessarily--
I mean, your own kids probably
don't say thank you either.
But they don't
necessarily love you.
They don't give you the hugs,
and kisses, and all the stuff
that makes it easier to do.
And so when I was
thinking about that,
I thought, huh, I wonder--
I was thinking about how
vilified stepmoms are
in so many fairy tales.
And then I thought I
wonder if those grew out
of this intrinsically
difficult relationship,
and that behind
these tales are just
ordinary flawed human
beings trying to get along
and trying to have
a relationship.
And that's where Agnes was born.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: I love Agnes.
How did you find
the right balance
of describing Agnes's
perspective from Cinderella?
Because there were so many
threads throughout the book
where you could see the
commonality between the fairy
tale and Agnes's version
of the reality of her tale.
How did you find
that right balance?
DANIELLE TELLER:
So I really wanted
it to feel like a real family,
like real people who are
struggling with these issues.
And so the most challenging
thing about the book
was trying to thread the needle
between making the stepmother
mother legitimately evil
because she couldn't
be this wonderful
person or there'd
be no story there, right?
So she had to actually
conform to the fairy tale.
She had to be a pretty
suboptimal parent
to Cinderella.
But at the same time,
I wanted the reader
to have developed enough
empathy for that character
that they could actually see
how she got to this place.
And so one of the ways in
which I tried to do that
was-- so I was
inspired by a story
that a colleague told
me a long time ago.
She was telling me
about how her child has
obsessive compulsive disorder
and her husband does as well.
And she was saying that it's
so difficult for her to parent
the child relative
to her husband
because she doesn't
intrinsically
understand the ways in
which his OCD affects
how he absorbs everything
around him about the world.
So she said, the
family goes to the zoo.
He steps in a puddle,
gets a wet sock,
and then he has to go
home and change his sock.
And she'll try to
talk him out of it,
and say, the whole
family is here.
Can't we just go without
a shoe and a sock?
And her husband will say, oh,
a wet sock is intolerable.
Of course, you have to go
home and change your socks
because he just has a much more
visceral understanding of how
the child is experiencing
that wet sock.
That she, not
having OCD herself,
couldn't really understand.
So this was a story she told me.
And I've thought
about that a lot
as a parent, how you understand
some of your children
more easily than
others because you have
traits in common with them.
And so I tried to
build this relationship
where the stepmother is
not a horrible person
or a good person.
Cinderella is not a horrible
person or a good person,
but they have this disconnect.
The way that they are in
the world is very different.
And the way Cinderella
has been brought up
is very different from how
Agnes has been brought up.
And so she really doesn't
understand the girl.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: In the
beginning of the novel,
Agnes says--
and I love this line--
compelling fiction often
obscures the humble truth.
How do you think fairy
tales and folklore
influence our expectations and
experiences in the real world?
DANIELLE TELLER: I
think fairy tales
are so appealing because they're
really morally unambiguous just
like Marvel movies or
a lot of the stories
that we absorb as children.
We know who the good guys are.
We know who the bad guys are.
We know who to
root for, and we're
going to be happy when
the good guy wins.
And we really don't care when
the bad guy gets blown up
or has her eyes
pecked out by birds
in the case of the stepsisters
because we know they're bad.
And so we don't have to
waste a single moment feeling
bad for them.
We can just clap our
hands, and say, ooh,
that was a great story.
I think that for
children there are
things that they can
learn from fairy tales
about how to be generous, how
to be good, how to be loyal,
and brave, and so on.
So there are I think
some good lessons
to be learned from fairy tales.
But I also think that our
natural tendency, especially
in the Western world, to put
everything in categories--
so this has been a way of
thinking that has been very
adaptive for Western society.
From Greek logic on, it's
given us the enlightenment.
It's given us
computers, the ability
to put things in categories and
say, if this, then not that.
This person is good.
This person is bad,
categories that are exclusive.
But those don't
apply well to humans.
And I think that
we have a tendency
to want to use that same way of
thinking as applies to humans.
And it's very satisfying
in a fairy tale.
But in real life,
I think it really
can trip us up
because, of course,
people aren't good or bad.
If you say, I'm a good person,
well, good relative to what?
Like who are the bad people
I'm comparing myself to?
And I think that gets us
into these ways of thinking
about people in jail must be bad
people because they're in jail.
And so therefore,
we can let ourselves
off the hook about sort
of caring what happens.
And we get into a tizzy
when people we think
are good people, comedians
who made us laugh growing up,
who seemed like good
people do terrible things.
Our heads explode
because we don't
know how to hold
that in our head
that, wow, this person
who I had slotted
in the category of good
person is now having
these behaviors that are bad.
And so in this way,
the novel really
is looking at the backstory.
So what if those categories
that we put people in really
don't exist?
And what if they're just people?
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: Which feels
so timely right now, not only
in teams we work
with, our families,
but our society right now
and our country right now
where it's so divided.
And just having moments
of trying to see
different perspectives is
challenging, but so critical.
It's something that
really stuck with me
after reading this book.
Maybe I actually
do spend some time
with my father talking
about politics.
Maybe.
Like maybe understanding
his backstory is good.
DANIELLE TELLER:
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: And
these categories though--
there's the aesthetic
part of it too.
And Danielle and I, when we
have been talking about the book
before, it was
interesting because we
shared an experience of the
original Cinderella fairy
tale, where when
we read this book,
Cinderella is so
lovely, and beautiful,
and blond with this
teeny-tiny little waist.
And Danielle and I
when we were growing up
were like, well, that's great.
But like, we don't
have blond hair.
And we don't fit that profile,
how her figure is drawn.
So we both really resonated
more with her stepsisters.
And I'm just
wondering what do you
think that does to people
long term when you don't fit
the idealized version of the
characters like Cinderella
or you resonate with
stepsisters who are seen
as more evil, and ugly, and
terrible, and all the things
you don't want to be?
DANIELLE TELLER: Yeah, I
thought about that a lot
writing the book.
And I think it's complicated.
It messed with my
mind a bit when
I was a kid because I was
this tall, lanky, dark-haired
person.
I didn't have the blond
curls or the tiny feet.
And so when I would play
games with my friends--
so we'd play make believe--
I'd always have to be one of
the boys, have to be a man.
I'd have to be the villain often
because I was much more manly.
And so I longed to be that
delicate little thing.
I longed to be that
ideal of feminine beauty
with the tiny feet and so on.
But I also feel in some ways,
it was actually really good
for me not to have
grown up feeling
that I could be the
Cinderella character because I
think it caused me to
put all of that aside.
I was like, nope, I'm not going
to be that pretty feminine
little thing so I may
as well just ignore
that, all the Cinderella
aspirations that I think
can be quite harmful
for children--
this leaning in for the
brass ring, the marriage
that's going to transform me.
You're going to go
through this portal,
and you'll be someone else
coming out the other side.
I didn't grow up
thinking any of that.
And I actually think that that
turned out to be a good thing.
I also think it's
really interesting--
because, of course, you
can be beautiful and not
conform to society's
expectations of what's
beautiful.
And so with the stepsisters, I
played with that a little bit.
So one of them is beautiful.
But because
fairness, fair skin--
fair, which means
beautiful, also means pale.
And that was very much the sort
of fetish in the Middle Ages
was to be pale, pale,
pale, like as pale
as you possibly could be.
So one of them is dark
skinned and doesn't
fit that ideal of beauty
even though she's beautiful.
But then the other
sister is disfigured
and even her mother doesn't
think she's beautiful.
And that's a really hard
thing for her in that society.
People still
believed back then--
what was it called?
Physiognomy, the
science that says
that what you look like actually
tells of your character.
So I can tell by how
broad your forehead is
or how small your
nose is whether you're
a mean person or a smart person.
So they actually in the
Middle Ages believed this.
So it was very hard for them
to not conform to that beauty.
But the sister who
is disfigured who
has no chance of anyone ever
thinking she's beautiful
is actually very freed by that.
She doesn't give a fig
what anyone thinks of her.
She's just been sort of
released from so much
of society's expectations
because she just
has to put aside this
idea that she could ever
be that ideal of feminine
beauty like her stepsister.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN:
And she becomes
such an interesting character.
She does so much that gives
her this other kind of beauty.
She's the one we
really root for.
Agnes goes through so many
challenges through the book,
so much upheaval, so much
she has to fight for,
yet the title is "All
the Ever Afters."
Where did that title come from?
DANIELLE TELLER: So it has
kind of a double meaning.
One of the meanings is
that throughout our life,
and Agnes is very
typical of this.
It's like climbing
a mountain where you
have these sort of false peaks.
And you think, if I
just get up there,
then I'm going to
be totally happy.
If I just get into
this university,
if I just get this job that I
want, if I just get this spouse
or if only I could become a
parent, or all of these things
that you think, OK, when
I get to that place,
when I win this award,
when I get this grant,
then I'm going to be happy.
And of course, we get to
that place, and it is happy.
It's not bad.
But it's never the ever after.
Then life goes on after that.
You're never at the pinnacle.
And so I think of life as this
series of happily ever afters.
So Cinderella gets married,
but her life doesn't end there.
She's happy she gets to marry
the prince, but it goes on.
And Agnes's life is
this sort of a series
of events good and bad.
And none of them are ever
after until the very end.
The other meaning-- one of
the things I find really
fascinating about the stories
because I think that we really
look at life through a narrative
lens is when a story has
a happy ending, like if you and
I are competing in a spelling
bee and you win--
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: I doubt
that would happen, but OK.
DANIELLE TELLER: But then you
get your happily ever after.
Yeah, I win.
But the story includes me too.
And so your story is the
happy, and mine is the,
oh, I'm so sad because
my dreams are crushed.
And so that's the other
meaning of all the
ever afters is it's not
just about one person.
It's not just about Cinderella.
It's about Cinderella's
stepmother,
her dad, her stepsisters.
It's about everybody's
ever afters.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: Love that.
So Ella is described throughout
your novel as somewhat
of a spoiled child,
incredibly different
from the idolized Cinderella
that we all know, yet she's far
more dimensional and realized.
How did you design that
character behind the idol?
DANIELLE TELLER: I
wanted there to be
this disconnect
between the stepmother
and her stepdaughter.
And I thought about what is
Cinderella like from the fairy
tale that we hear.
She's sweet.
She is kind.
She's very quiet.
She's obedient.
She always follows the rules.
She's maybe friends with
animals in the Disney version,
actually in the Grimm
brothers' version as well.
And so I wanted to create a
character where she could be
like a real-- because that
doesn't sound like a real--
as a parent you think, that's
pretty one dimensional.
I can't imagine a child
who's only those things.
But I thought that people who
are not neurotypical often
have some of those
traits like being
more loyal following and so on.
And I'm surrounded by people
like that in Palo Alto
and in my family.
[LAUGHING]
I could see that disconnect
between somebody who grew up
in a very rough and tumble
world living with this girl who
had many privileges, who
sort of hasn't learned
the same life lessons,
but who also just
has a very different
way of seeing the world.
She's so much quieter.
Agnes's daughters are
very physical and so on.
And she's much more like--
I think she describes
her at one point like sun
sparkling on the water.
There's something about her
that's a bit more dreamy,
that's a bit more interior.
And so I wanted to make
it so that the Cinderella
character wouldn't be spoiled.
I didn't intend for her
to come across that way.
And I think one of the things
that's a real challenge
us the story is told
in the first person,
so you really only get
Agnes's view of everybody.
And so I had to show
that she's feeling
disconnected from this child.
But I tried to have other
characters in the story come in
and show how much they love
the Cinderella character,
how much they think she's this
wonderful child, which she is.
From Agnes's perspective, they
just have this disconnect.
So that was what I was
trying to go for so that you
can understand how Agnes was
not the best stepparent to her,
but you could also see that
it's not Cinderella's fault
that other people adore her
and think she's the best thing.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN:
But I think she's also
described at some point as
almost a vessel for anyone
that she comes in contact
with because she is maybe
less three dimensional than one
might imagine that people could
put their own desires of
who she should be upon her.
DANIELLE TELLER: Yeah, although
that was more a commentary
on celebrity.
So what I was
thinking of there is
how we admire these
gorgeous human beings
in Hollywood or elsewhere
or like Princess Diana.
When I was a kid, people got
up in the middle of the night
to watch the royal wedding.
And it was such a big deal,
and we all got our haircut like
that, and we all
wore the little-
MICHELLE KAUFMANN:
Some of us still do.
DANIELLE TELLER:
--frilly colored shirts.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN:
Not me, just a friend.
[LAUGHING]
DANIELLE TELLER: So we all
wanted to dress like her.
But we didn't know
anything about her.
I mean, she was a celebrity.
She was an unknown.
She was a blank parchment.
She was that person that we all
had these longings, these sort
of inchoate longings
that we projected
at her or at movie stars.
But it's not about who
they are as people.
It's really about our own
desires and our own longings.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: So who
I loved most in the book
is our main character Agnes.
She's so strong.
She's so resilient.
She fights so hard for what she
believes in and for the people
that she loves.
She says at one point in the
book to her two daughters,
every woman serves a master be
it an overlord or a husband.
And she is fortunate
if he does not
beat her or treat her cruelly.
Everything you
have I got for you
either through
marriage or hard work.
There is no alternative.
The men in this novel are
often careless and even cruel
while the women show
resilience and care.
Can you talk about your choice
of the writing of characters
that way?
DANIELLE TELLER: So I'm not
sure there's such a stark line
between the men and the women.
But certainly, Cinderella is a
story about women and women's
lives.
And throughout the
world and over history,
women have often been treated
much more like possessions
than like real people.
Even though the women lived
within a very narrow sphere,
I wanted to show the
full sort of richness
of their lives and
their characters.
But I mean, they're
not all great people.
In fact, some of the
people who torture
Agnes the most-- there's
her boss the nurse when
she's a kid who's
pretty evil toward her.
And then much of
her disappointment
comes from the abbess who
she at first admires so much.
And so the women are certainly
not perfect characters.
And I think that the men are--
they are a little bit more side
characters because it
is a story about women.
But I think that they are
also very, very complicated.
And part of why I think we
see them as more negative
is again because we're seeing
them through Agnes's eyes.
And she had a very complicated
relationship with men
because she lives in a society
where it's impossible for her
to have a relationship
of equals with a man.
It's just not set up that way.
And she knows it.
And she really resents
the fact that they
have so much more
freedom and so many
more entitlements than she has.
But at the same
time, she needs them
to be able to survive, to
be able to get ahead and do
what she wants in her life.
And so she's got this
complex relationship
where when she feels any sort
of tenderness toward a man,
it feels to her a little
bit like weakness.
And I don't know if maybe it
was hard to pick up in the book.
But I was trying to
get at, especially
with her husband,
when she marries
Cinderella's father, that he's
completely besotted with her.
He really loves her.
But she can't admit
that to herself
because it's just
too complicated.
She needs to like hold that at
arm's length and sort of stick
with I need to take care of me,
I need to take care of my kids.
I can't let myself get too soft.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN:
Women mentoring women
is definitely something I
think a lot of us think about.
It's certainly something
that I think about a lot
and I've benefited from.
And I try to actively
make time to help with--
it's definitely a
theme in the book
both in really beautiful
and powerful positive ways,
but also in hurtful,
tragic ways.
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
DANIELLE TELLER: Sure.
So Cinderella's--
not Cinderella.
Agnes, the stepmother,
is born a peasant.
And so she has no
access to education.
But she learns to
read when she's
a servant when this elderly,
very wealthy, very powerful
countess, who maybe is somewhat
eccentric for the times--
she believes in
girls' potential.
And so she teaches her to read.
And it's not a coincidence that
the daughter of this countess
is the very powerful abbess
who is the fairy godmother, not
magical.
But she's the godmother
figure in the story.
And young Agnes, when
she's a teenager,
she's really drawn to this very
smart and charismatic woman who
is one of the most
powerful people in a very
religious country at the time.
And so she wants to follow her.
Her heart just
goes to this woman.
And she decides that she
wants to join the church
and to follow in her footsteps.
But what she can't see--
I mean, there's
a class division.
And so she doesn't
quite understand
the way in which being
of such low birth
means there was never
any chance of this.
But also, I wanted
for the abbess
to be a character who has
achieved great things,
but then kind of pulled up
the ladder after herself.
When I was in
medical school back
in the early 90s, some of the
women doctors I really admired,
especially in fields
that were very male
dominated at the time like
surgery and cardiology,
who were really mean.
And at the time, we said, my
fellow female students and I,
they had to be that
way in order to make it
in such a tough field
at such a tough time.
If they hadn't had that
sort of personality or that
like rough exterior,
that they would not
have been able to make it.
And I think that the abbess is
one of those sorts of people.
But as I've gotten older, I've
also felt like didn't they
owe it a little bit to the
women who came behind them
not to pull up the ladder
quite so hard behind them.
And I wondered how much
being a powerful woman
in a male-dominated
world makes you
feel even better about
yourself than if there
were a lot of other
successful women
because maybe that makes
you even more special
that you're the only one.
You're the only one
who could make it.
So anyways, that's
this character.
She fulfills a bit of that rule.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: I love that.
So good.
And it's so true too.
There is really a truth in that.
I want to open this up.
Do folks here have
questions for Danielle?
I don't want to
dominate her completely,
although I have plenty
more to ask her.
But yes?
AUDIENCE: Hello,
thank you for coming.
Interesting discussion.
So the question I wanted to
ask was around your process.
So did you write like on the
weekends, or in the mornings,
or evenings?
Can you give us any
insights to that?
DANIELLE TELLER:
Sure, so I had started
working on this book
when I was still working
full time as a physician.
But then I later quit and
became a full-time writer.
So at first, I was mostly
working on airplanes,
flying back and forth
across the country
because I was working in Boston
and living in California,
which is kind of nuts.
And I read a lot of books
about the Middle Ages
to try to get some of
those details right.
And then when I started
writing full time,
I really tried to
treat it like a job
just like when I had to
go into my workplace.
So I have the luxury of
being able to start later
in the morning.
I get to go exercise first
thing in the morning.
Nobody's paying attention
to when I actually
get onto my computer.
But I really try to sort
of set aside those hours
from sort of mid-morning until
time to start making dinner
and just work through.
At least for me, it's
not possible to be
productive and creative
through that entire period.
When I feel like I'm
running out of steam,
I try to spend time doing
other things like research
for other projects,
or for that project,
or sort of like reading
on backgrounds so
that it's still
part of my work day.
Because I think it's
really easy as a writer
to just procrastinate
and for things
to go year after year
without getting done.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: So the book
was set in a medieval setting.
So you did quite
a bit of research
I'm imagining for this book.
I know you visited castles--
hearing about some
of your trips.
Can you talk a little bit
about that part of the process,
the research part for this?
DANIELLE TELLER: Yeah, so mostly
I read books in the beginning
just about what medieval
villages were like,
what medieval castles were
like, that sort of thing
to have a sense of the life.
But a lot of it was
on Google and YouTube.
It's amazing how much
you can find out.
There are people who
are hobbyists who
brew beer in a medieval style.
You can actually go on
YouTube and watch somebody
making medieval beer.
And so I've learned
so much by people
who have done this research
for their own amusement.
Yeah, so that was
a big part of it.
And one of the
things I discovered
when I was doing the
research is that there's not
much known about the poor
people from the Middle Ages.
So the rich people, who
could read and write,
we have fairly good records
at least of who married who,
and whose kid was who, and
all that sort of stuff.
But for the illiterate
poor, nobody
was writing anything about them.
And so we actually
know very little.
What we do know is
mostly from having
exhumed bones from
graveyards, and looking
at what ages children died,
and trying to figure out
what children died from.
And the few tax records
that existed at the time
tells a little bit
about the villages
and so on, like who had to
pay taxes on how many oxen.
And that's kind of
it, which actually
was very comforting to me.
Because I was really
worried about getting
historical details wrong.
And then I realized, well,
even the historians are arguing
about what actually happened.
So I felt a little more
relaxed after that.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN:
Do other folks
have questions for Danielle?
I have one.
I was wondering about and
thinking about this discussion.
So you have children
and step-children.
If they were to write a
book with you included,
what do think the
title would be?
DANIELLE TELLER: Of
my book about me?
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: Yeah,
written from your children's
perspective.
DANIELLE TELLER: It would
be "What's for Dinner?"
[LAUGHING]
I'm serious.
I mean, that's how
kids are, right?
They don't really see
their parents as people.
The story would go like this--
once upon a time, there
was this nice lady.
She cooked really good food.
I love her.
The end.
[LAUGHING]
MICHELLE KAUFMANN:
That's kind of I think--
DANIELLE TELLER:
And as it should be.
They've got their
own stuff going on.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: They do.
So what are you working on now?
DANIELLE TELLER:
I mentioned I had
this novel in the back
of my mind for 10 years.
Well, so I finally got
around to writing that.
So it's not historical fiction.
It's actually set in 2003,
which isn't that historical.
And it takes place
in Canada in Toronto
during-- there was a big
blackout in the northeast
of the United States
and a big chunk
of Canada in August of 2003.
And the inspiration
for the story
was the poem "The Love
Song of J. Alfred Prufrock"
by TS Eliot, which is one
of my very favorite poems.
And if you're not
familiar with it,
it's narrated by a
character who is approaching
or in middle age, who has a
big decision, a challenging
decision to make.
And it sounds like it's
of a romantic nature,
though we never find out
exactly what this choice is.
But what's so tragic
about the poem
is that he knows even before
he made the choice, that he
doesn't have the guts to do it.
And the reason is that he
lives such a comfortable life.
He's got this very
upper-middle-class
comfortable life.
Like I've measured out my
days with coffee spoons,
women come and go,
speaking of Michelangelo,
all those lines that talk about
the sprinklers on the streets.
It's just this beautiful,
comfortable life.
And he just cannot smash that
all to bits to do this thing
that he wishes he might
have the courage to do.
And so in my story,
the Prufrock character
is a woman in her 60s,
who's planning the birthday
party of her mother.
And the other main character
is her daughter-in-law.
And we sort of watch
their parallel lives.
Even though they're 25,
30 years apart in age,
they have very similar
trajectories of their lives.
And they come together
at a certain point,
and they take very
different paths.
So the older woman is the one
who didn't have the courage
to take a chance.
And the younger woman sort
of smashes everything apart.
She leaves her
husband for a woman
she's fallen in love with at
work and just creates havoc.
And it sort of
follows both of them
through the blackout
where they each have
their sort of separate
epiphanies about their choices
and what they've
done in the world.
And the reason I chose to
set it during the blackout
is that my brothers were both
living in Toronto at the time.
And they told me
about how amazing
it was when all the lights
went out that people actually
came out of their houses
and onto their stoops.
And they talked to
their neighbors.
And people had barbecues.
They had block parties basically
because the only way you could
eat was to grill your food.
And so I think in a blackout it
can go in very different ways.
I mean, there could have
been rioting and looting.
And it could have been
horrible, but it turned out
that people volunteered
to go direct traffic.
It really brought
the city together.
And so I think for the J.
Alfred Prufrock character,
she's lived her life in fear.
And then she sees that humanity
does have this goodness.
And I think that that
really sort of causes
her to realize that maybe the
fears she's been living under
was misplaced.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN:
Oh, it sounds so good.
When is it going to come out?
DANIELLE TELLER:
When I get it done.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: We'll
look forward to that.
So unless folks have other
thoughts or questions--
yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: Oh yes, I
can repeat the question for you.
If you were to write
about another fairy tale
and take on a
different perspective,
what would that be?
DANIELLE TELLER: So that's
a really great question.
I have thought about it.
I haven't come up
with a great answer,
one of my favorite fairy tales
is "Beauty and the Beast."
I really like that Belle
has a little more agency
than Cinderella.
And she's really making choices
for other people in her life.
So I like that fairy tale,
but the twist I haven't really
come up with.
So the original fairy
tale some people
think us based on a man
who had hypertrichosis.
So he had this very rare genetic
disease where he was basically
covered in hair.
So people with this
condition, they
can grow hair all
over their bodies.
And so his face was
all covered by hair,
and he married this
beautiful woman.
He was upper class in France
and married a beautiful woman.
And so I love that story because
what I don't like about Beauty
and the Beast is that
he turns into a prince,
like literally he has to
turn into this babe for her
to like really be like,
OK, now I'll marry you.
But I really like
the idea that he
becomes beautiful in
her eyes because she
falls in love with him.
So I've been playing with that.
I haven't quite come up with
the right sort of take on it.
But if I were to do
a twist, it would be
that he doesn't turn beautiful.
That she just sees
him as beautiful
because she loves him so much.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: Yeah, you
should write that one too.
That sounds good too.
[LAUGHING]
All right, well,
thank you so much.
DANIELLE TELLER: Thank you.
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: And thanks,
everybody, for joining us.
Thank you [INAUDIBLE]
for sharing this with us.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIELLE TELLER: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHELLE KAUFMANN: So good.
[APPLAUSE]